I'm coming to this realization that our
family home is slowly turning into a
commune
our driveways kind of turned into a
parking lot
ten cars one Airstream which is pretty
typical
what is going on in here today we're
eating gay there's like cake everywhere
with regularity you can bet there's some
kind of crazy project going on in our
house and today is a big photo shoot for
Julie's vegan gluten-free cake book
which she's been working on for a long
time they're prepping and shooting
seventeen cakes today it's quite the
operation tip-top once again numb down
again stand up to that questions right
it really does take a village right now
we have ten people living at our house
and everybody helps out the word commune
has this sort of hippie pejorative
definition to it or connotation but the
truth is communal living is really how
our ancestors survived difficult times
it was through a village coming together
and in our modern-day world we've really
gotten away from this idea we live these
isolated fractured lives where we're in
our car where our office work oyster
dinh our apartment or our home
and we really don't reach out
fundamentally I think that's wrong I
think that we've really gotten away from
the benefits and the beauty that can be
experienced by a more collective
communal way of approaching your daily
life that's what this experiment is all
about and so far it's been really
beautiful
walk downhill with me all the planks are
set up well it's like you're building
like a real house yeah the front will be
here always facing facing east and then
we have a 6-foot deck in front and two
feet around and in the middle what is
that that's a fire pit we might go to
the flea market and get a vintage tub
where's the pig in a live what are you
gonna name the pig Charles we actually
are building a commune here there's
construction to prove it we're growing
our own food people are living in
teepees they're taking baths outdoors
and how much food is this garden gonna
generate definitely a lot it's not a
huge space but it's definitely enough to
feed how many people we have here we
really go through a lot of food we go
through a ton of food alright thanks you
guys
this is Andrew Andrew lives here how is
life in the airstream better than life
and you where else is it the best place
you've ever lived
absolutely I'd be set so Andrews an
artist how long has it been since you
been living here I've been here over a
year Wow yeah and rain your daughter is
how old she's five
how does rain like living in an
Airstream I was concerned that rain how
rain was gonna react to it but she loves
it she loves it
yeah everything is like it's like a
dollhouse board and then right over here
I'm going to show you where we're going
to be laying down containers for
additional studio space as we begin to
expand the Kamiya so Andrews container
space is going to be over there this lot
right here was originally intention to
be a container for me to build an office
but I can't quite afford it right now so
that's going to have to wait trapper
might take it over instead the idea is
to try to mimic the main house
we got to put some cool huge windows in
some decks in some skylights and
subtract light again by Andrew okay
every day is different which is really
kind of a cool way to live actually we
feel more like we are caretakers of this
property and the idea behind this
property is to leverage what it has to
offer to be a place of spontaneous
creativity hi I'm doing a monologue on
the Jai commune awesome it's all about
living an authentic creative life we're
extremely fortunate to be able to live
in this extraordinary amazing place but
one thing that we could say about it is
that in many ways we don't feel like we
are the owners of this property we are
merely its stewards almost everybody who
comes here is expressing something
creative so it's really been an
incubator for creativity for
spirituality and unlike yeah so
everything that Julie and I have kind of
accomplished or achieved over the last
10 15 years really was birthed in this
home everything from writing finding
ultra to the plant power way which most
of the photographs in that book were
shot here all the recipes were
cultivated in the kitchen here we have
converted the garage into a professional
analog 24 track recording studio I
shouldn't say we the boys really did
that and they are in the process of
recording their first album with their
band analemma
we're getting container spaces here to
really begin to create multiples on
creative work and living space here to
expand the vision and the reach and
expand the region that
yeah the inspiration and the and the
activation and the share
rain of what gets created here you know
hopefully it inspires other people to do
similar things in their own spaces and
in places around the world it's been
incredible it's incredible to have this
extended family and to share you know
values and experiences of life so you
know we meditate together we practice
yoga together we're preparing food
together and then we're holding vision
and supporting each other in all of our
creative endeavors mm-hmm very very
grateful to be here again we don't take
it for granted at all and it's a
pleasure and an honor to introduce to
you guys a little behind the scenes of
how we live our life on a daily basis
that's right and I gotta go I have
another picture shoot go take pictures
of the meeting right here bye
from oh we're trying to start a
revolution through septic tanks bring us
their waste
well javi I read it more the guide and
you know I very happen